the makers of The Secret Life of pets -
want us to believe that our pets can
perform oddly fantastic acts but what if
they're actually capable of the things
they do in the movie we'll show you how
it all makes perfect sense in the real
life they know how to party
if the Toy Story movies have taught us
anything it's that there is a good
possibility that we humans do not know
what goes on after we leave the room
toys may come to life have meetings make
plans and get into shenanigans so if
it's possible for toys then it's
certainly possible for pets and
according to the secret life of pets -
they know how to party when they're
humans leave the house
apparently our pets crank up the radio
and dance they socialize with each other
and they play video games it makes sense
that they would become masters at
entertaining themselves if they're home
all day and it's not too far off these
according to bark post pets have been
caught on their human's pet cams
rearranging furniture playing dog Jenga
and helping themselves to groceries so
yeah these pets know how to party they
can drive okay this one sounds a bit
crazy but it's not as nuts as you might
think animals try to imitate human
behavior all the time we've heard dogs
say we've seen cats doing housework and
there's even a video of a dog lid JIT
riding a bike so if our pets can perform
everyday human tasks they could
potentially pick up driving and no we're
not only talking about cartoon dogs the
secret life of pets - shows us exactly
what they would look like but we went a
step further and found actual footage of
a real-life dog learning how to drive a
car so this is actual proof that dogs
can drive to remind us that anything is
possible
even this next surprising pet ability
unlikely friendships cats dogs bunnies
tigers and monkeys don't get along right
well the secret life of pets - seems to
have a very different opinion according
to this film it's totally possible for a
dog to work with a cat and apparently
they all come together to rescue a tiger
from the circus we thought that was
pretty bizarre until we investigated it
further think
to the internet we found a mother cat
who adopted a baby bunny we've seen
horses and dogs be best friends and
we've also seen a bird who was feeding a
dog spaghetti so of course it makes
sense that the animals in this movie
would form unlikely friendships - but
that's not even the best part
trust us you're gonna want to watch
until the end for the most astonishing
pet discovery ever they work out most
people will probably chuckle when they
see snowball the bunny gearing up to
lift that pink weight he claims that
he's going to be the first bunny with
washboard abs but who's to say that pets
don't think about keeping in cheap we
give you Exhibit A in this video there's
a realized cat doing pull-ups it looks
like this cat might have been going hard
on the Fancy Feast and now needs to get
in shape we think this is substantial
evidence that pets do indeed work out
but do they experience emotions the same
way humans do do you think so and here's
the proof hmm human emotions anyone who
has seen those pet shaming videos knows
that our pets are capable of human
emotions they can be joyful sad scared
angry and even neurotic and anxious the
secret life of pets - explores the
underlying cause of their weird
pathologies like this cat who doesn't
understand why his human throws out the
bird corpses he brings her as gifts in
the hamster who doesn't understand why
he runs and runs on his wheel but gets
nowhere that would drive anybody nuts
and research shows that animals
experience emotions intense enough to
require therapy so pets being in a
psychologists office like the one in the
movie makes complete sense in real life
this next pet behavior is even more
bizarre until you see what we discovered
watching TV the secret life of pets
expects us to believe that hamsters and
other pets watch TV like humans do at
first we didn't believe it but then we
found out this interesting fact
according to National Geographic
domestic dogs can perceive the images on
television almost the same way as humans
can and they're proven to be smart
enough to recognize the images on the
screen if they see animals they react
the same as they would in real life even
if they've never actually seen that
animal before there's a viral video of a
dog reacting with a major
emotion to that famous scene from The
Lion King where Simba loses Mufasa to
the Stampede why is this mouse on my paw
still looking a doggie date it seems
unlikely that our pets could put
together such a complex set of plants
the way they do in secret life of pets
too however a new study finds that some
animals are capable of planning for the
future according to the study Ravens and
apes are capable of making plans and
thinking ahead and if Ravens and Apes
are capable of this it's possible we'll
discover this ability in other animals
too they teach us most humans are
determined to train their pets they
teach them how to do tricks and how to
follow rules but what about the things
our pets teach us the secret life of
pets two points to this idea with the
little boy who copies the behavior of
his canine friends so do humans learn
from animals psychology today believes
they can professionals believe that our
pets can teach us how to love
unconditionally stay in the present
moment and focus on what's important
what have you learned from your pets
tell us in the comments the underground
city of animals in a big city you would
think that most of the animals live
above ground as pets right well secret
life of pets showed us that there is a
whole underground city full of animals
and while it may seem like that's only
true in the movies it's more real than
you would think New York actually has a
ton of underground animals inhabiting
the city and beyond animals that live
underground and in the shadows include
moles rats bats mice squirrels possums
and skunks some animals are more
comfortable in the dark and buried
spaces of the city if they can be heroes
it doesn't matter how big or small they
are our pets have huge capacities to
love and protect us and while we get to
witness animals performing major heroic
acts in the secret life of pets movies
this is not uncommon in the real world
as well we all know about service dogs
as well as dogs that work for the police
to keep us safe but dogs aren't the only
animal heroes we found there's a story
about three lions who guarded and
protected a kidnapped girl in Ethiopia
until she was rescued and there was once
a pot-bellied pig who saved her owner
when she was faced with cardiac arrest
she ran out into the road to get help
for her human that is one heroic
Pig do you have any weird pet stories
we'd love to find out about them in the
comments thanks for watching the things
we hope you enjoyed our video before you
go give it a big thumbs up and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button
we'll see you next time
[Music]